[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامجكم
الندوه صالونه اليوم مختلف شكلا وموضوعا
ربما تلاحظون هذه الاعلام الموجوده على
الطاوله طاوله الحوار وايضا هذه القطعه
الفريده التي ربما تستعرض لاول مره في
الاعلام
سنفاجعكم عن لماذا نستعرضها باللونها
الغريب انها الرايه السعوديه الاولى هذه
القطعه الجميله التي ترونها هي حسب ما
اكده الباحثنا وشريكنا اليوم في الندوه
الاستاذ عدنان الطريف الباحث السعودي في
الماثورات التاريخيه السعوديه الماديه
والمعنويه لكن احنا اليوم حديثنا عن اشياء
الماديه استاذ عدنان الاعلام وانا ايضا
اعرف انك اهتمام بالصور لكن سيكون حديثنا
اليوم عن الاعلام فمرحبا بك في هذه
المساحه مرحبا فيك استاذ مشاري انا السعيد
بوجودي في العربيه حياك الله السؤال الاول
خلينا نسال عن هذه القطع التي زينا بها
صالون اليوم العلم السعودي القديم الذي
خبرتني انه من ماثورات الدوله السعوديه
الاولى قطعه اصليه حدثنا عن هذا العلم ثم
سنلج بعد قليل الى تاريخ العالم السعودي
بس انا هذه القطعه الفريده كيف حصلت عليها
كيف وثقتها وما هي دلالاته لونها وشكلها
اليوم احمد الله سبحانه وتعالى انه تقريبا
من 36 عام وانا اجمع كل ما له علاقه
بالرؤيه السعوديه او بشعار الدوله السفن
ونخله حقيقه من خلال بحثي استطعت انه اجمع
كثير من الاعلام في البدايات لم اكن اعرف
حقيقه تاريخ هذه الاعلام ولكن
بالربط من خلال ما ذكر تاريخيا في بعض
المصادر اضافه لانه انا بعد اقتنائي
هالقطعه وغيرها من القطع يمكن بعضها
فعلا قمت
بتوثيقها وسالت عن اكبر المراكز العالميه
وكان من ضمنها مركز سيران في فرنسا
لتوثيق مثل هذه القطعه ما هي مهام هذا
المركز المركز من اكبر المراكز في العالم
في عمليه رصد وبحث وتحليل
القطع او من ضمنها القطعه القماشيه بمركز
معتمد حللت مجموعه من الاعلام التي
اقتنيها من ضمن هذه القطعه وهذا اشاروا
انه في حدود 1727 في هذه المرحله هذا
العلم يعني دعنا نقول بحدود 300 عام الا
قليلا تقريبا طبعا هو مش دقيق بالضبط
مشاري المركز حقيقه يعطيك ثلاث تواريخ
متقاربه يعني يعطيك بنسب معينه
يعني 47% في هذا التاريخ 22% في هذا
التاريخ ويعطيك البقيه في تاريخ ثالث ولكن
انت تشتغل في رينج معين انه انه
وتحليل المعهد العلمي الفرنسي سيرام
المعتمد في تحليل القطع الاثريه هل اكتفيت
بهذا التوفيق ابدا انا حرصت تماما انه انه
اصل وابحث عن كل الشخصيات المحليه ذات
اهتمام قريب من هذا الجانب وفي مجال
التاريخ
ولله الفضل منا استطعت انه احصل منهم على
التقارير من خلال فحص هذا الاعلام والوقوف
عليه لانه ليست ليس هذا العلم ولكن هناك
اعدام اعلام كثر حقيقه في مراحل مختلفه
استطعت فعلا ولله الفضل منا من اساتذه
ودكاتره ومن بيت المطرف محمد الرايه من
1906 استطعت انه احصل على تقرير كل شخص
تقريبا في حدود 6 7 صفحات احنا اردنا ان
نضع بس لمحه عامه عن هذا العالم لان ذكرني
كنت ادردش معك بحديث
لمستشرق او رحاله اسباني ادعي الاسلام
صحيح
سمى نفسه علي العباسي وحضر كما تعلم ولا
يخفى خطبتك وفطنه المهتمين من المشاهدين
موسم الحج عام 1807 للميلاد وذلك الموسم
قاده الامام سعود بن عبد العزيز شخصيا
ومعه جيشه ومن اهل نجد واهل الجنوب وهو
تحدث عن انه شاهد الامام بعينه في مكه وفي
المشاعر وقال انه شاهد الرايه السعوديه
وهي خضراء مرسوم عليها كلمه التوحيد ربما
تكون هذه الرايه الله اعلم ممكن هو فعلا
هذا المستشرق والرحال حينما انتقل من
المغرب الى مصر ومن مصر ارتحل مع الاخوه
المصريين الذين كانوا للتو انتهوا من قسوه
الكعبه فعلم انه موسم حج فارتحل معهم وكان
هذا الرجل دقيق دقه متناهيه في عمليه
الوصف والتحليل
حينما دخل الى مكه وصف الكعبه المشرفه
ووصف الحصير اجلكم الله على السامعين
الكسوه الكعبه الحمام
الزي في حينما انتقل المشاعر المقدسه فعلا
شاهد الجيش الامام بما ان ذكرنا قبل قليل
الاسره الكريمه المطرف حملت الرايه هلا لك
ان تضع لنا مسرد تاريخي عن ابرز الاسر
التي حملت الرايه السعوديه من الدوله
السعوديه الاولى الى وقتنا المعاصر
الحقيقه للامانه المصادر التي كتبت قليله
جدا فيها في هذا المجال يمكن الشيخ عبد
الرحمن بن رويشد والشيخ حمد الجاسر رصد
حقيقه العلم المناسبه التطرق انه انه
البيرق او البيارقيه اللي كانوا من الدوله
السعوديه الاولى والثانيه كان حقيقه يعني
من ابرصهم ببيت بنطوق سليمان بن سيف بن
طوق وابراهيم بن طوق وعلي بن طوق ومن
بعدهم حقيقه الحميد السلمه هذا اللي اللي
مع الامام محمد بن فيصل في الدوله
السعوديه الثانيه في في معركه جودا كان من
شجاعه هذا الرجل ان ربط نفسه بالساريه كما
ذكر الشيخ احمد الجاسر في كتابه انه انه
يعني تشجيع للذات انه ما ينهزم لانهم مع
سقوط
وفعلا وهو قتل قتل في معركه جهده ربط نفسه
يعني لتشجيعا لنفسه في كثير من البيوت
التي حملت الرايه يعني حتى من احفاد
الحميدي الحميدي السلمة صالح بن هديان
ابراهيم الظفيري
الى ان وصلت في عام 1906 عبد الرحمن بن
مطرف اوكل له الملك عبد العزيز
المعشوق حقيقه في عهد الملك عبد العزيز
اثناء خروجه من الكويت عبد اللطيف المعشوق
حمل الرايه الى دخول الملك عبد العزيز في
الرياض وابنه منصور حمل الرايه من بعده
ومن ثم يعني حقيقه سلمت
اعتقد انه توفي في معركه البكيريه وما هي
المواصفات التي تتطلب في حامل الرايه يعني
المثل اللي ذكرته قبل قليل منتهى الشجاعه
الصراحه نعم من اهم الامور المتعلقه بحمل
الرايه ان لا تعطى الا حقيقه
صاحب باس قوي شجاعه حكمه
ذاب يعني قوه جسديه مع سقوط وللاسف يعني
يسقط الجيش كانه رمز معنوي او ماده
للدوله وعاده يتم اختيار البيارقي ان يفوق
من سواه من حيث
الحكمه
والصبر والقوه الجسديه لانه ما توجد في كل
شخص طبعا اذا مصطلح محلي يعني حامل البيرق
او
يقال الراعيه والعلم
بما انه حول حول طبعا احنا نحب نذكر
المشاهدين ان احنا نعقد هذه الحلقه
بمناسبه الامر الملكي بوضع يوم يوم العلم
من كل عام يعني
فنحن في في اجواء هذا تحت رايه هذا العلم
ان نتحدث هذا الحديث استاذ عدنان تحدثنا
عن حمله الرايه من الذي خط العلم
حقيقه
في البدايات الاولى كان الخط خط مما يبدو
لي يعني بسيط مثل هذا العلم جدا جدا ولكن
انا من خلال بحثي
وحاولت اسال واتوصل لمن قام بخط العلم
وجدت انه من البدايات الاولى
السيد عمر عاصم الحسني من اهل الجموم في
وادي فاطمه في مكه ممن ارتحل من مكه الى
الكويت وحينما زار الملك عبد العزيز
الكويت في 1910 ميلادي كان هو موجود في
الكويت وعين مديرا للمدرسه المباركيه
جدا وخط العلم الكويتي اللي كان باللون
الاحمر وكان يحمل كلمه كويت وهو من اوائل
من خط العلم السعودي بشكله الكوفي وفي
مرحله متقدمه حينما امر الملك عبد العزيز
طيب الله ترى بافتتاح دار الكسوه في مكه
في عام 1926 عين عبد الرحيم بخاري وهو من
يقوم بكتابه
كل الايات القرانيه في كسوه الكعبه من ذلك
الوقت
فكلف بكتابه الاعلام السعوديه
وتطريزها حتى انه الاشراف على العمليه كما
هو بالعلم اللي امامك العمليه
السنبله اللي كانت موجوده كان يعمل على
تصميمها شارك اخوه لنا
عرب
ومسلمين من باكستان في كتابه البدايه
الاولى للعلم رصدت من رصدي انه في اعلام
طبعت في امريكا بان زيارات الملك عبد
العزيز الى ارامكو كثير منها من امريكا
وخطه من قبل اخوان اعتقد عرب او باكستانيه
ولكن في الاساس طيب في سؤال ملاحظ هذا
العالم بشتى مراحله حتى لو كان خط بدائي
مثل ما نلاحظ في علم الدوله السعوديه
الاولى او خط اكثر تطور بالذات مع الدوله
الثالث
خضراء اللون جزء ابيض منها يلي الساريه
كتبت عليها اقرب الى هذا الشكل نعم لا اله
الا الله محمد رسول الله ويعلوه سيفان
متقاطعان لم يذكر ابدا هلال نتعرض بعد
الفاصل لان ازفه وقت الفاصل الى التحورات
او التطورات البسيطه اللي اضطرت على
العالم هم الفرق بين علم الملك الخاص وبين
علم الدوله اذا ثمه خلط هنا وعلاقه
السيفين والنخله اللي شعار الدوله وعلى
يعني الفروقات بين هذا الامر وايضا فكره
من هو صاحب فكره العلم اصلا تعرف هذه صار
فيها نقاش ايضا العلم الحديث فاصل وجيز لا
تذهبوا بعيدا نحن في هذه المساحه الخضراء
نتفيا العالم السعودي
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا فيكم من جديد حديثنا كان وما
يزال عن العلم السعودي بمناسبه اطلاق يوم
التاسيس احببنا ان نصنع او يعني نحاول ان
ننسج حلقه مختلفه شكلا وموضوعا ولذلك كما
تلاحظون معنا في الاستوديو اعلام سعوديه
قديمه اهمها العلم الذي يمتد من الدوله
السعوديه الاولى الذي تحدث عنه ويقتنيه
شخصيا الباحث السعودي عدنان الطريف المهتم
بالماثورات التاريخيه السعوديه والحقيقه
يملك الرجل قطع اطلعني عليها يعني ينوء
بحملها العصبه الى القوه من الرجال متنوعه
سواء الاعلام او حوامل الاعلام السواري او
غيرها يعني مهتم بادق التفاصيل وانا كنت
اقول وما زلت اي شخص لديه شغف في موضوع ما
يستحق ان يكون مقدما في الحديث فما بالك
اذا اضاف الى الشغف علمه استاذ عدنان
تعرف الجدل الذي دار حول من هو صاحب فكره
العلم في العصر الحديث
[موسيقى]
ولكن اذا ان ظهرت على شكل الحالي ولكن
حقيقه امر انه انه الشيخ حافظ وهبه هو من
صمم هذا العلم اعتقد لا يوجد لها مصدر
كبير طبعا
للشيخيه للدقه التاريخيه وهو من اهم حقيقه
طبعا استاذ عدنان الان الملاحظ انه في
تطورات طرات على العلم اول شيء بنشوف يعني
ايضا شرد سريع ما هي ابرز التطورات التي
طرات عليه العالم مع ثبات عناصره الرئيسيه
وبعدين بسالك ما هو الفرق بين علم الملك
وعلم الدوله بس قل لنا اولا ايش التطورات
اللي طرات على بشكل مختصر جدا استمرت
الرايه السعوديه الاولى استمرت الرايه
السعوديه من الدوله السعوديه الاولى
والثانيه وبدايه الملك عبد العزيز متطابقه
في الشكل الملك عبد العزيز في في حينما
دخل الرياض زي ما قلنا انه العلم كان يحمل
سيفين نعم سيف سيفان متقاطعان وبعدين
من بعد ذلك ضم الى سيف واحد وفي مرحله
متقدمه اقر العلم بشكل الحالي في عهد
الملكه عبد العزيز في عهد الملك سعود
استمر استخدام العلم بنفس المواصفات
السابقه ولكن في كثير من الصور نجد انه
على مواقع الملك سعود عاده في كثير من
المناسبات استخدم نفس العلم بس يستخدم
العلم الملكي الذي يحمل السيفين
النقل الكبيره في في تطور العلم هو في عام
73 ميلادي حينما
كلف الملك فيصل رحمه الله عليه
قبلها بقليل عام 76 كلف لجنه بعضويه
الامير سلطان بن عبد العزيز
والشيخ 76 قصه قبل لان الملك فيصل
756 66 نعم 66 عام 66 ميلادي
كلفت لجنه
بعضويه الامير سلطان بن عبد العزيز
والشيخ عمر السقاف وزير الدوله الشؤون
الخارجيه والشيخ صالح الحصين
للتفكير في موضوع نظام العلم
عملت اللجنه لسنوات ومن ثم اجتمعت مع
السيد احمد عبد الوهاب اللي ورئيس المراسم
الملكيه ومن ثم رفعت التوصيات واقر نظام
العلم في عهد الملك فيصل ب 22 ماده فصلت
في كل شيء اعلام السيارات الضيوف
والاستقبالات مواقع وضع العلم محاذير كانت
شامله اضافه لان الماده الاخيره من النظام
اشارت الى ان يكون هناك صدور نظام يعني
نظام تنفيذي وفي عهد الملك خالد في في عام
88 78 ميلادي
ظهرت من سبع مواد اللائحه التنظيميه للعلم
وفي عام النقل الكبرى في عام ميلادي مع
صدور النظام الاساسي للحكم كانت الماده
الثالثه في عهد الملك فهد طيب الله ثراه
واموات المسلمين
كانت الماده الثالثه
تتحدث عن العلم انه العلم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لونه اخضر
يعني النسب
وحددت يعني نقاط جدا هامه
تساند ما كان موجود في في عام 73 ما هو
الفرق بين علم الملك وعلم الدوله في عام
بعد قرار مجلس الشورى وافق عليها الملك
عبد العزيز طيب الله ثراه ونشر في في
صحيفه ام القرى
اقر الملك من بعد موافقتها على قرار مجلس
الشورى علم الملك
والعلم الوطني وعلم الملك وعلم سمول العهد
والعلم البحري والعلم التجاري وعلم الجيش
وعلم الطيران العلم في ذلك الوقت في عهد
الملك عبد العزيز والمعلومه قد لا يعرف
الكثير انه الملك عبد العزيز
العلم الخاص بالملك والعلم ولي العهد هو
ما تراه الان امامك اللي يحمل نعم سيفاني
متقاطعان او سفينه متقاطعين يعني هذا علم
الملك عبد العزيز الخاص نعم بهذا
المتقاطعه هذه قطعه اصليه اصليه نعم
استخدمت على السيارات ترى كثيرا
الملك سعود حينما قابل العلم هذا حقيقه
حينما قابل الملك سعود الملك فيصل الثاني
ملك العراق في المنطقه الشرقيه كان هذا
العلم عندي فضول كيف حصلت عليه
كلها بالاقتناء والشراء حقيقه والانتقال
من مكان لمكان والسؤال اصبحت حقيقه يعني
محترف في مجال الاعلام انا اشتريت من
امراه معلش دقيقه من خلال بحثي وصلت الى
امراه في امريكا مدرسه ومحلله تقاعد عمرها
بالسبعين
ابوها كان موظف في الامم المتحده
وفي الخمسينات بعد انشاء
المتحده بخمس سنوات كانت عدد الدول 51 سنه
51 دوله دوله
تواصلت معها وقلت انا شفت على مين نفس
العالم هذا السيفين والعلم السعودي الحالي
تواصلت معه واشتريت لواحد وخمسين علم عشان
فيها الاعلام السعوديه الاثنين
فابحث وحاول اتواصل على الاعلام عن
الطاوله ماذا عن العلم الذي بجوارك العالم
هذا كان حين ما زال الملك عبد العزيز
البحرين كان على سياره الملك عبد العزيز
انا ملك مقطع فيديو يوثق هذا العلم كوني
مهتم بالصور التاريخيه والنادره اذا
اقتنيت عنهم احاول بشكل او باخر اربطوا
بالصور الموجوده عندي الى ان اجدت على
فكره
كتابك الذي اطلعتم عليه
تضع شرح موسع امام طبعا بالمناسبه انت رجل
من اكبر جامعيه صور صحيح يعني عندك هذا شق
اخر لم نتحدث عن بس لاحظت في هذا الكتاب
في كميه كبيره من الصور تضع على كل صوره
شرح تاريخي لها مناسبه التقاطها تاريخها
الشخصيات التي كل الصور مربوطه بالاعلام
وكل الصور مربوطه اول كتاب عن العالم
السعودي
نحن نتحدث عن واقع بحثي كم استغرق منك هذا
البحث ست سنوات حقيقه وفي معلومات قد تكون
يمكن يعني
من النادر وجودها يعني انا انا اللي اكون
معك اكثر صدقا يمكن لو ما اثير خلال
الماضيه موضوع يعني خطاط العلم لم ارغب
بالافصاح عن مجموعه من المعلومات
التاريخيه اللي تعبت في الحصول عليها
بسهوله حقيقه لكن العربيه تستاهل
والعلم حقه ان يشاع ويذاع يعني لكن انا ما
وجدت هذا الكتاب ان شاء الله نجده قريب في
الاسواق يعني
واتمنى ذلك ان شاء الله ان شاء الله باذن
الله لعله قريب ان شاء الله اليس الصبح
بقريب لكن استاذ عدنان
لماذا العلم بشكل عام دعنا من العالم
السعودي لماذا العالم دائما يمثل حاله
وجدانيه لدى مواطنين كل دوله يعني شوف
الحديث عن العلم السعودي طبعا وهو علم
مميز شكلا وموضوعا يعني لكن هذا الحنين
هذا الارتباط بين الانسان وبين علم دولته
بماذا تفسر شكل هذا يدل على على اهميه
ومكانه وانعكاس وحب وولاء لان العلم له
دلالاته رمزيه رمزيات رمزيه ودلاله العلم
السعودي حقيقه بما يحتويه من لفظ الشهاده
السيف يدل على القوه والعدل والرخاء
والنماء احنا كمواطنين
يحق لنا حقيقه ان نفخر ان هذا علمنا لانه
يعني تعكس الدوله من خلال علمها مدى
ارتباطها في المواطن ونجد فعلا انه انه
انه من يقرا فعلا كل دلالات العلم السعودي
ولا العبارات التوحيد مناسبه لعلم القديم
اللي عرضته كان في الاصل لون اخضر
ربما مع الوقت يعني استحاله اللون يعني
عندي اعلام لونها كم الم تقتني
والله المهمه المهمه حقيقه يعني
اكثر من 50 علم
فيها بعد تاريخي تشكل متحف اللي فيها بعد
طيب لماذا لا تقيم متحف على الاقل للاعلام
وانا شفت ايضا الشواري نعم سواري اصليه
راس الساريه الرمانه واشياء ايضا عندك قطع
اخرى يعني بس خلينا في العالم اعتقد انه
يعني تعرف اقامه ان يكون هذا العالم جوهره
التاج فيتوسط
والحمد لله انت اطلعت علينا كثير من
الاعلام ويمكن لاحظت تستخدم مشاري يعني
لما شرفني
العلامه اللي خاصه بالملك عبد العزيز في
مناسبته للملك عبد العزيز وجدتها من
مصادرها يمكن ما بعد يمكن رجعتها شفت
التغليف
فانا اربط العلم بمناسبه وجوده واربطه
بالصور كوني مهتم بالصور مساله المتحف هذه
امكانيه دوله انا انا
دقيقه 36 سنه من عمري استطعت ان اجمع هذا
انا اعتقد انه لانه جهد مميز وواضح يعني
ليس كلام في الهواء يعني شيء ملموس نلمسه
بايدينا يعني وليس حديثا عابرا واعتقد انه
جدير خاصه انه
يعمق الاحساس
بالانتماء الى هذا اللون بالانتماء الى
هذه الرايه من خلال ابعاد ماديه ملموسه
يراها الانسان بعينه ويلمسها بيده وربما
يشمها بانفه ويشم معها عبق التاريخ
وتضحيات الاباء والاجداد كم سقط من انسان
تحت هذه الرايه كم لعلع الرصاصهم من حولها
كم سله السيوف
وتنادت الصيحات والنخوات هذا كله مختزل في
حديث مثل هذه كم جرى من احاديث سياسيه تحت
ظل هذا العالم كيف بني هذا البلد يعني
ايضا كما انه كفاح عسكري وسياسي
وعسكري وحربي انا في الحقيقه
عاجز عن الشكر هذه مجرد تطواف يعني
ويكفي كما يقال من القلاده ما احاط بالعنق
لكن نحن نريد قلائد اكثر وجواهر تفضل اختم
مشاري والمشاهد الكريم انا املك وثيقه قد
تكون الوحيده الممهوره من بختم الملك عبد
العزيز تتحدث عن الرايه وهي اصل حقيقه هي
الوثيقه الوحيده يعني اللي فعلا تتناول
العديد من
1327 هجري
تتحدث عن امور استعاده الرياض بكم بثمان
سنوات اصليه نعم نعم اصليه نعم اصليه نعم
والملك فيها الملك المؤسس تحدث يتحدث فيها
عن مواضيع مختلفه حول الرائع انا اظن اننا
هذا بحر لا ساحل له ومفاجاته حافله غايه
الشكر لك استاذ عدنان الباحث السعودي في
الماثورات تاريخيه ومنها العلم السعودي
وغايه الشكر لكم على تخصيص هذا الوقت
لمتابعتنا وهذا التطوها في الاخضر تحت
افياء العلم السعودي الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]